So let's answer our SMT
versus dual-core quiz.
We have a floating-point
intensive thread.
It's going to use pretty much these two
issue slots and very rarely use these.
And then we have an integer-only thread
that only gets to use these two.
So, with a dual-core processor,
one of the cores really gets to be
2-issue plus maybe a little bit.
Another one gets to be just 2-issue
because it never sees floating-point
instructions that it needs
to have more than 2-issue.
In SMT however,
we would be able to do two
instructions from this thread and two
instructions from this thread per cycle.
So we will be getting very
similar performance, and
as we have seen, then this is the more
effective approach because the cost
that we are getting here,
versus here, is significantly lower.
So we get similar performance for
a almost half the cost here.
Now what will happen, however,
if we didn't have a floating-point
intensive thread and
instead got two of these?
In that case, the two core is slightly
more cost effective because it gets
the 2-issue performance in each core for
twice the cost of one core.
Whereas this gets us
the performance of a single core.
because both of these are sharing
the 2-issue slots for
a cost that is more than one core.
So in that case, this will be
the more cost effective option, so
as you can see it's not that SMT
always wins over multiple cores,
it's that it depends on exactly what
types of programs we have and exactly
what's the distribution of issues among
units and how different applications
are using it So the floating
point intensive, an integer only.
And this type of a split
between issues slots
is an extreme example that
makes the SMT look really good.